[Música]
la droga conocida como tranque es el
producto de Mezclar un sedante animal
llamado oscilacina con fentanilo un
estudio publicado en junio en Estados
Unidos alertó que la silacina fue
hallada en 36 estados en muestras que se
tomaron solo en Filadelfia el
medicamento animal estuvo presente en
90% de esas muestras y la prevalencia
fue de 25% en Nueva York El problema es
que los consumidores quedan indefensos
por horas y al volver a recuperar el
conocimiento No solo hay dependencia de
más sino que se generan en la piel
heridas que dejan como resultado o
tejido muerto y que al no ser atendidas
frecuentemente terminan en amputaciones
la conversación sobre este tema es con
lineal con Franco ella es médica
especialista en toxicología clínica
máster en ciencias del sistema nervioso
y es especialista en investigación de
neurotectoxicología Muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros y bienvenida
directo a América
Bueno muy buenos días para todos quienes
nos están escuchando Saludos desde
Colombia Bueno hablemos sobre trunk
siempre le ponemos estos nombres a las a
los contaminantes no es la primera vez
que sucede Digamos que ya supimos hace
un tiempo el cocodrilo no sé si si
escucharon hablar del cocodrile que era
una heroína de origen siberiano que
venía contaminada realmente
la silacina es muy parecida a un
antihipertensivo que nosotros usamos en
el día a día que se llama clonidina Solo
que nosotros lo usamos por vía oral Y es
de menor potencia y esta sílacina
realmente Es de uso veterinario no está
aprobado su uso en humanos Entonces
digamos que ese es el primer problema
más que drogas zombie porque digamos que
a todo le ponemos drogas zombie Lo que
sucede es que con tal de disminuir los
costos de la producción del fentanil que
es la droga que está matando más de
90.000 personas en los Estados Unidos y
que adicionalmente ya está distribu
latinoamérica ya están muchísimos países
alrededor de Europa pues le adicionamos
un contaminante para que sea más
económica su producción y su venta
entonces específicamente eso es el
tranque si la cima que es un producto
veterinario combinado con fentanil
adicionalmente la silacina baja mucho La
presión y es muy probable que esta
disminución en la presión arterial sea
la que produce lesiones en los vasos tan
intensas A qué se enfrentan los
consumidores y las autoridades con el
auge de esta mezcla que pues obra
decirlo es mortal no
si desafortunadamente ya veníamos en un
problema que el narcán que es la
naloxona que es el fármaco con el que
digamos revertimos los efectos de los
opioides en sobredosis como fentanil
morfina heroína no funciona en cuanto a
las hilacina entonces nuestros pacientes
hacen paro respiratorio o deprimen su
sistema nervioso central y no hay como
sacarlos de ahí en este momento no
tenemos nada con qué manejar la silacina
la única manera es desde evitar el
consumo y evitar que se contamine y Cómo
podemos explicarles a los televidentes
estas laceraciones que aparecen en la
piel de los consumidores al final lo que
enfrentan estos consumidores son
necrosis
exactamente entonces la mayoría de las
de los contaminantes que utilizamos
tanto en la cocaína como es el levamisol
el el en el cocodrile que es el fósforo
blanco y la silacina que es el fentanil
van a producir como no son hechos para
el tejido venoso humano porque
usualmente esto se aplica por vía
intravenosa entonces produce inflevitis
que es inflamación de las venas y del
tejido que hay alrededor y se generan
necrosis o sea es los excipientes o sea
lo que acompaña al fármaco lo que
termina siendo un daño adicional en la
piel podemos decir que este problema va
más allá de la mera digamos aplicación o
moda de drogas sintéticas se lo pregunto
porque la política de lucha contra las
drogas ha sido muy dura y muy radical en
las últimas décadas y una actitud hacia
la legalización Usted cree que podría
evitar que productos como este
potencialmente más peligrosos entraran a
ser en el mercado ilegal
definitivamente definitivamente
una regulación de las drogas que traiga
productos con calidad estándar como pasó
con el alcohol para los que no sepan la
cafeína el café también era ilegal lo
que pasó con el tabaco podría llegar a
ayudar no es una solución definitiva La
regulación no va de todas maneras ni la
legalización va a terminar con con el
consumo de drogas por fuera pero sí
probablemente va a disminuir los riesgos
sobre todo de que estas drogas estén
contaminadas y que aumenten las muertes
y que se vuelvan un problema de salud
pública para los países con costos
económicos y sociales Pues que son
incontables Bueno sobre eso quería
preguntarle si en América Latina nos
vemos o nos podemos ver de alguna manera
afectados porque Generalmente nos llegan
las noticias de más al norte
exactamente actualmente hay fentanil en
Colombia Definitivamente hay frente en
Colombia hay frente en Latinoamérica
pero en este momento no es nuestro mayor
problema nosotros tenemos un problema
muy grande sobre todo en Colombia con un
por el consumo una sustancia que se
llamaba suco que es una cocaína de baja
calidad en la cual se consume fumada Y
tenemos más de de Diez mil adictos a
esta que los tira las calles pero eh va
a llegar cierto eso va llegando se va
globalizando va llegando las la este
tipo de drogas no es muy común y se
terminan quedando a veces en sus zonas
de origen por ejemplo con el cocodrilo
Nunca tuvimos más de un caso reportado
en el país Esperamos que no suceda con
la silacina bien ha hecho falta Y esta
es mi última pregunta enfocarse más en
el consumidor y en su bienestar para
atacar estos fenómenos de sustancias
dañinas cuál sería su recomendación para
tratar no solamente con esta mezcla de
drogas sino con otras a los pacientes o
a las personas consumidoras
definitivamente es un problema social
muy grande que tiene que ver con los
determinantes y por eso países que han
disminuido su cuidado de bienestar
social a sus habitantes son los que
tienen consumos de drogas más altos
Entonces eso sí es clarísimo si no hay
inversión social en educación y en salud
en trabajo las medidas punitivas no van
a disminuirlo ya lo ha mostrado que la
guerra contra las drogas digamos que ha
sido fracaso ha sido un fracaso porque
por ahí no se va en algunos países como
Nueva Zelanda han tenido campañas muy
exitosas en las cuales a los jóvenes lo
que más les ha ayudado no es campañas
directamente contra las drogas sino eh
estilos de vida saludables Y darles la
posibilidad de hacer muchísimas otras
cosas más allá pero tenemos un montón de
habitantes de calle por ejemplo ustedes
ven en la ciudad de Los Ángeles hay
miles de habitantes de calle en
Filadelfia que es en este momento donde
tienen el problema más grave en los
Estados Unidos hay muchísimos habitantes
de calle que llegan a cualquiera
consumos tenemos migrantes tenemos
personas sin trabajo tenemos veteranos
de guerra entonces todo este problema
social se vuelve una bola de nieve para
que terminemos consumiendo y cada vez
nos venden cosas más basura literal o
sea cada vez le adicionamos más basura a
las drogas que ya conocemos pues viene
el dinero de hablar con Franco médica
especialista en toxicología clínica
gracias a usted por brindarnos esta
información
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación y a
nuestros televidentes quédense con
nosotros se vienen más datos valiosos en
directo a América
[Música]